All
right. All right. So, today we'll be
talking about how we went from 1.8
million prompts down to just 30 alerts.
Uh, it's the story of how we were
hunting abuse in a userdefined Agentic
ecosystem. I am Matt Riddinghouse. I'm a
lead security data scientist here at
Salesforce.
>> My name is Millie. Nice meeting you. Uh
Matt and I both work on the data science
team on the cyber security operations
center group as part of the broader
Salesforce security or so. So let's dive
right in. So we all know that we are now
officially past the chatbot era. Um so
in this wild west of agents, we aren't
just sending prompts to an LLM. We're
equipping models with an increasing
level of autonomy. So when an agent is
no longer a blackbox or just a prompten
enriched call to our LLM, it is now a
privileged system executor capable of
executing code and manipulating
infrastructure. Um so now when your
agent can autonomously call API or query
databases, the threat surface really
explodes. It stops being about just bad
words and starts being about
unauthorized system execution.
Um, just a quick check-in with the crowd
here. How many of you are either
currently or in the near future
defending an agentic system this year?
>> Okay, cool.
>> Awesome. And how many of you are looking
to anomaly detection as part of your
toolbox?
>> Well, that's awesome. Cool. All right,
let's um dive in. I hope you guys find
this interesting and or relevant. Um, a
little bit background setting. So we're
at Salesforce we work on something we
called Asian force which is your
digitalized workforce. Uh we do have the
product or the platform enabled or
implemented both on our customer orgs
and our internal Salesforce orgs. Um so
here's a snapshot of uh what we're
dealing with on a daily basis in terms
of scale. Um, so now that creates a
blackbox defense challenge where we
cannot rely on static signatures because
every agent's logic is custom and valid
behaviors vary wildly between what we
see here on our 55,000 organizations
that we monitor on a daily basis. So,
what we needed was a defense that could
scale up to these 12,000
unique daily active agents without
having to manually tune for each one of
them. Um, and I want to set the stage
for the scope of the problem we're
walking you through today. We now here
have a trust challenge where we cannot
look at let alone train on your prom
data because that's our customer data,
your data. Um but what we're trying to
do here is to protect customers and
ourselves for that matter actually from
the actions invoked from the output of
the LMS that are generated from your
prompt data. Now how do we do that? Um
we built defenses at the execution layer
which sits outside of but works
handinhand with the reasoning layer of
these agentic systems.
Um so that brings me to our threat model
just really quickly. Um because I'm sure
you guys have like seen some version of
this. This is our lens of looking at
this. So when we're dealing with
autonomous agents in this multi-tenant
SAS environment, we look at our threat
landscapes in two buckets essentially.
Bucket one, your platform target
attacks. So this involves attackers
finding cracks in your implementation of
this platform. So maybe that's a
misconfigured permission set uh or flaw
in a custom Apex skills are exposed to
the reasoning engine. Uh and then we
have bucket two uh which we call abuse
of a legitimate agency. So these are
threat actors using the agents
legitimate built-in capabilities to
perform actions that are valid but
malicious in context. Um the bottom line
here is we we aren't just defending
against bad words here. We're defending
a massive multi-tenant execution engine
where your legitimate logic is
constantly evolving. Um a little bit on
force. Uh we do have a set of guardrails
which we we call the trust layer. Not
going to go into details. Um but you've
seen this across industry. Um pretty
common to have this content moderation
layer that focuses on the reasoning
layer. Right? So that's your dialogue
between the user and the LLM. While that
is critical for filtering and screening
for things like toxicity and prompt
injection, the content moderation alone
is not enough for the following reasons.
Um first we will talk we touched upon a
little bit earlier is reasoning versus
execution. So while you do have the
content moderation layer that polices
the reasoning layer which is your
thought process the it cannot see the ex
execution layer right. So that's the
actual system calls. You also need guard
rails that police the specific actions
and invocations triggered from by the
agent. And then we also have the
blocking dilemma because your content
moderation layer often captures
malicious intent but lacks the
highfidelity signal required to do
things like automated inline blocking in
an enterprise context. Um so what we
developed here um this detection model
provides the behavioral context
necessary to move from just flagging to
confident automated response. And then
lastly what we have what we call the
postgeneration blindness. So even if in
a scenario where your prompt is deemed
as safe the resulting agent plan might
involve an authorized data access or
privilege escalation that traditional
content filters just cannot observe
hence act on. Um so with that um we walk
through the challenges what do we do and
how do we deal with that. I'll hand it
off to Matt and he'll walk you through
our solution for that.
>> Yeah. So now that we have this agentic
ecosystem in place, um building
detections around it really comes down
to how do you go about detecting
anomalies and historically I I think uh
detection engineers have looked to uh
anomaly detection as a pretty big part
of the toolkit. Um but typically at the
user level or around specific tables or
entities. Um, one of the things that I
really want to highlight is changing in
the uh, Genai era here is that we no
longer have to just be constrained to
the user level. Uh, you can actually
also consider the context of the agent
itself as a new axis for anomaly
detection. Uh, especially when you do
this in the context of the organization
that's building and deploying those
agents, uh, you essentially end up with
three levels of context that you could
use for anomaly detection. uh if you
have a data science background, this
lends itself extremely well to something
called an ensemble model uh where you
can start to really pair these different
levels of context together uh to
minimize noise. I think anyone that's
done anomaly detection knows that it can
be very noisy uh especially if kind of
deployed quickly. So uh combining these
three streams together and then using
them to kind of reduce noise AC sorry
across all three really helps make this
a meaningful and impactful model.
Yeah. So uh we started by trying to
quantify intent and we did that with a
simple and well scoped hypothesis which
was just that looking for agents
accessing things that they normally
don't would be a good way to find
anomalies in the ecosystem.
uh when we had that hypothesis in place,
we then started to look at what features
could we actually put in place to
measure those kinds of anomalies. So we
started looking at how frequently were
Agentic sessions accessing data, what
types of access were they doing? Are are
the agents just selecting data? Are they
updating it? Are they deleting it? Um
can we build filters or features around
that? Um and so by keeping those uh
feature sets simple and the hypothesis
simple, we started being able to
investigate where does our coverage work
versus where does it not work. Um we
started to find out um what are the
legitimate edge cases, what are the
issues with what we're measuring. Uh is
it effective or is it not?
Uh I want to talk through some of the
features that we did look at that were
pretty essential to how the model
operated. Uh so we really tried to
consider data access from both kind of a
depth standpoint and a breadth
standpoint. So we were looking at things
like the frequency of calls to our
databases. Uh what proportion of data
was actually being accessed by these
agents uh which gives you a good
standpoint of depth. Uh especially if
you are looking for data xfiltration. Is
somebody pulling the entire database?
Are they just accessing one customer's
records? uh really trying to understand
kind of those ratios was pretty key for
us.
Uh another good thing that we looked at
was we started to quantify the
sensitivity or the rarity of the data
being accessed. So uh in the Salesforce
database as you were kind of building
these out we have uh feature flags for
things like fields that might contain
PII or sensitive data. Uh we also try
and do profiling to understand how
frequently are agents touching certain
columns or fields uh and really
understand what data is being accessed
how frequently uh those kind of helped
build out the features.
Let's move to the next.
So as you kind of combine these things
we really looked to incremental
historical profiling. So every day we
would actually build a profile of all of
the sessions that had occurred in a
given day. Uh this let us quickly
assemble a historical context and a
baseline. Uh and then we were able to
quickly identify anything that was
actually out of character based on the
historical baseline. So uh as we
continued to aggregate kind of a rolling
history uh it was really easy to look at
standard deviations or anomalies kind of
from that historical baseline.
One of the benefits of this is that as
new sessions occurred, we could really
score them quickly after the session
occurred or even as it was ongoing uh to
identify our outliers and proactively
respond. Uh this kind of deviation based
or standard deviation based scoring also
helps kind of build alert prioritization
into the system as well.
I want to also cover some of the things
that didn't work for us. And again, this
is uh one of the major downsides to
consider when building these ensemble
models is if you start to consider
features across these multiple layers of
identity, uh the number of features that
you're going to be building into your
models will explode very quickly. So
every new data rarity or data frequency
feature that you add, if you were
looking at it in the context of the
user, the agent, the org, you're
building out multiple layers of these
features. Uh, and it can create noise
and complexity very quickly.
I do also want to call out one of the
things we built that didn't work, which
was we built a pretty large uh query
complexity calculator early on. Uh, it
was customuilt. It took a lot of code.
One of the reasons that it didn't work
for us um was just that it kind of
confused layers of identity. So we
thought that malicious actors would
essentially be looking to run these
complicated queries or that it would be
a good way to identify anomalous
queries. Um what we were finding was
that the agents themselves were
constructing the queries. So uh just
make sure that your features are
measuring what you think they are
measuring. Uh it's a good way to find
the edge cases that are important here.
Uh we also found a pain point in
joining data in from multiple tables. So
we had to reach out to get uh contextual
information from uh metadata tables
around the queries being executed. Uh
this built in a number of really
expensive computational joins for us. So
uh later on we were able to actually
refactor the model to essentially
operate on just one table, remove the
expensive joins and have the model train
in a third of the time.
At the end of the day, the results um
speak for themselves. We we had a nearly
two million daily prompts uh which we
were able to filter down slightly
through the trust layer. Um but through
the behavioral anomaly detection model,
at the end of the day, we had fewer than
30 active alerts that needed
investigation.
One of the things that we also did was
we tried to lean into an agentic
paradigm where we now expect that agents
are also going to be involved in the
investigation and triage of the alerts.
So what you see on screen here is an
actual example of an alert. But what
we're doing is creating a structured
JSON payload that is then ingested by an
additional agent that helps make sense
of that payload.
And so the agent is able to very quickly
take the features that we provided and
synthesize a summary of why the alert is
anomalous. Um typically in plain English
and one of the advantages of that is uh
it's very customerf facing very
friendly. We don't necessarily have to
assume that the investigator has a
security background.
>> Thank you Matt. So we talked about um
the state of the world that we we built
this um tool into. Let's talk a little
bit about the road ahead. Um so the
ultimate goal for really any security
practitioner is moving from knowing what
happened yesterday to stopping what is
happening now. Um so in our current
pilot uh version of this model we accept
a 12 to four 24hour detection latency as
both the training and inference pieces
are running in batch jobs. However, our
architecture is built for the hot path.
So by taking the behavioral baseline we
learned during our daily batch
processing and eventually pushing them
to a high-speed cache, we could
eventually perform the inference piece
in flight. Um, so if a session hits our
critical threshold, meaning it's
essentially statistically impossible for
this to be normal behavior, we don't
wait for sock analyst to triage the
alert or um notify the customer hours or
sometimes days later. We move to autoc
containment. Uh we can kill the session
uh revoke the token or trigger a bot
level immediately. This is how we'll
eventually close the loop at the
execution layer of an agentic system.
Um let's talk about some of the lessons
we learned along the way. Um first one,
our major hurdle was the observability
gap. So in the beginning we had these
engineering logs that told us what
happened. But um the security telemetry
didn't really tell us who or which agent
was responsible for what in a way that
supported what we wanted to do which was
highfidelity detection. So your mission
here really is what we call identity
multiplasking. You have to partner with
your engineering and product teams early
on to ensure that your agentic logs
aren't just debug strings. They need to
be structured events that link the
invoking user ID to the agent ID.
Because without this context, you're
blind to the um abuse of a legitimate
agency case where you just cannot
distinguish between what a power user is
and what a compromised agent might look
like.
Um, secondly, don't wait for a known
attack to build your defense. So, in the
environment we operate in where there's
12,000 plus unique daily active agents,
a signature-based approach is
essentially just a blackbox failure. You
need to start profiling what normal
looks like today, especially for aset
rarity features like those that Matt has
just walked you through. So then you
have the statistical mean ready when the
deviation does occur and then you can
act on it immediately.
Uh lesson number three practitioners
ourselves included often fall into the
trap of building the perfect feature. We
spent a significant amount of amount of
time and resources on this so-cal parser
and query complexity model that
ultimately just introduced too much
complexity and latency for what we
eventually wanted to do which is
near-time or real-time action. We found
that simple telemetry like invocation
count or sensitive asset frequency
produced way higher fidelity signals
without having to blow up our SLAs's.
And finally, remember that your funnel
is only as good as your baseline. Do
expect noise for the first 14 days of a
new agent's life. Build that warm-up
period into your socks playbook so you
don't burn out your analyst on day one.
And with that, um, it's a wrap. We will
open up to questions. Thank you so much
for being here.
This is great work, Millie and Matt. Uh,
so I have 100 questions. I'm only going
to ask one. Um, the curse of
dimensionality.
How did you get over all of this
overgineering the features and all that?
Can you give us some more details? Yeah.
So, I I think for me the the main thing
was to kind of just start with a pretty
open canvas and be able to brainstorm.
Um, and I I kind of took some
inspiration from something like PCA
where it was like really just how can we
actually look at which features are
contributing the most signal. Um, so we
had several rounds of kind of creating
features, running some analysis on how
predictive were they actually in uh
predicting abuse and then we used that
to kind of callull the feature set down
to the most minimal set that we could
that would actually have the predictive
power that we needed. But yeah,
>> and I can go to into like a just tiny
little bit of implementation detail. So
you could actually think of this as like
hyperparameter tuning in like a
traditional ML model, right? Like given
that the this is the set of feature,
this is what outcome look like. You can
essentially run a simulation and you can
map that out and you can actually tune
your detection logic and the resulting
detection volume output that way. So
like um we actually bro built this kind
of programmatically too. So there's a
lot of like uh kind of feedback loop
architectural design you can leverage
here just you know like traditionally
how how we did like ML already but
>> uh two questions about um how about like
uh so the final output of a set of 50
odd whatever uh were you guys also have
you guys also thought about like some
some sort of like confidence score on
those alerts and how about like
annotation piece as well to say whether
this was right or wrong for it to act as
a feedback loop.
>> Yeah. So I I think um one of the things
is again we use that deviation based
scoring. So for every axis that we're
actually looking at, we get some
indication similar to a confidence
interval of just how far out of
character is this for the normal user's
behavior. So you know maybe a support
agent shouldn't be pulling the entire
database. It would be extremely out of
character. So that that gives some
telling of confidence. I I think we're
still kind of working to tune that a
little bit better as we proceed. Um, and
then we're continuing to work with some
uh teams internally to kind of work on
scoring the alerts that we have now. But
yeah,
>> hey, awesome presentation. Um, I really
loved also the slides on um the
autocontainment like ideas and um
explanations that you're given to sock
analysts just make it easy to reproduce.
Um, what are you hearing from the
instant responders and sock analysts on
the signals that they're receiving and
then what they want to actually do about
it? I'm really curious about this autoc
containment that might happen in the
future with AI agents and then what
actions they might want to take like
what are you hearing from them?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I can I can speak to that.
So that's a that's a a multi-layered
question. Uh well first of all like our
first stab at like how do you make the
result one more human readable and
interpretable uh because we always see
in ML there's this trade-off intrinsic
trade-off between your accuracy and
interpretability um our first step by
that well twofold one is we
specifically designed the algorithm to
be simple to to be able to trade out for
that interpretability so you have to
remember in like a enterprise SAS kind
of context we talk about Salesforce we
give this alert to customers or we give
this alert to a sock analyst. They need
to be able to actually understand it and
then be able to act on it. So our first
design choice was choose a pretty simple
distancebased algorithm. Uh number two
um the slide that we went through uh
where we give you a sample alert um
using essentially using LM to help you
interpret um the result. That's like our
second step at making this more human
readable and more actionable and what
you might want to do with this. Um, so
that's the first layer of just making
the alert itself useful. Now moving to
the inline or blocking or autoc
containment that's extremely hard of a
problem space because you're you're
talking about you're basically letting
your algorithm not only make decisions
for the user but also act on their
behalf. Um so our approach to that the
the the model just pilot rel is just
pilot releasing to customers this month
actually. Um but our approach is we're
having a purple team exercise where we
have a red team essentially generating
that and we're going to have the model
catch it in the wild and then that's how
we're going to be tuning efficiency.
>> Thank you.